unsavory posts taunting freezing up some
actors fell to the dark side and got
fired from one of the most iconic
franchises of all time keep watching to
see the star wars actors who got the
boot
currently gina carano is the most high
profile name in star wars mostly because
she was fired from the mandalorian the
most high profile project in star wars
the former mixed martial artist who
served as din jaren's ally cara dune was
dropped from the show for repeated in
politics statements on social media in
the past she's posted statements that
have been viewed as anti-mask and
transphobic but the tweet that broke the
internet's back compared the current
american political climate to nazi
germany it's a good rule of thumb to
avoid comparing anything to nazi germany
and carano violated that maxim in a big
way she posed the rhetorical question
jews were beaten in the streets not by
nazi soldiers but by their neighbors
even by children because history is
edited most people today don't realize
that to get to the point where nazi
soldiers could easily round up thousands
of jews the government first made their
own neighbors hate them simply for being
jews how is that any different from
hating someone for their political views
many readers understandably took offense
at that comment and demanded she be
fired from her job and disney obliged
even though the star wars franchise
started on the big screen it has found
surprising success on the small screen
as well before the mandalorian was even
a glint in john favreau's eye shows like
the clone wars and rebels demonstrated
the viability of the franchise in tv
form however these shows weren't without
their own controversies especially the
animated star wars series resistance
star wars resistance takes place before
and during the force awakens and
includes a few familiar characters
including general leia organa originally
rachel butero was supposed to voice this
cel-shaded incarnation not surprising
since butera previously voiced leia in
star wars battlefront 2 but at the last
minute vutera was scuttled and replaced
by carolyn hennessy while disney never
made an official statement the running
theory is that rachel butera was fired
for posting a video that mocked dr
christine blasey ford the sexual assault
victim who testified against
then-supreme court nominee brett
kavanaugh butera's twitter account has
since been deleted increasing the
intrigue surrounding this one since star
wars is a sci-fi epic spaceship
dogfights come with the territory as
with dogfights on earth the best pilots
tend to emerge victorious while luke
skywalker is a skilled pilot thanks to
his connection with the force you can't
find a better non-jedi pilot than wedge
antilles despite the character's legacy
his beginnings were a little rocky in
the casting department initially
antilles was portrayed by colin higgins
he's the antilles audiences see in the
rebel briefing during star wars episode
4. while higgins had previous acting
experience it was all on tv where the
cast gets to rehearse according to
gerald holm who played tesic from return
of the jedi the film didn't have
rehearsals so higgins struggled with his
dialogue which consisted of one sentence
eventually higgins spoke a line that was
shorter than intended after only one day
of struggling higgins was let go and
replaced by dennis lawson ironically
when lawson originally auditioned for
the role of wedge he lost it to colin
higgins still this firing and recasting
earned higgins the moniker of fake witch
and eventually the anthology book from a
certain point of view retconned higgins
as cold tackbrite
some of star wars most important roles
have gone to puppeteers everyone knows
about mark hamill but without people
like the late kenny baker non-human
characters such as r2d2 would have never
been possible one of those talented
puppeteers was almost lost thanks to
harrison ford tim rhodes brought
numerous characters such as salacious b
crum and admiral ackbar to life
throughout the original star wars
trilogy not surprising since rose
studied under the great jim henson but
that didn't mean bubkus to ford
especially after rose and the other
puppeteers laughed during the famous
scene where han solo is unfrozen from
carbonite after ford complained rose
ribbed ford's complaint which everyone
found funny except for ford he overheard
the ribbing and said he wouldn't step on
stage until the guy who made fun of him
was fired so an assistant director told
rose that he was fired except it was all
for show in truth rose was allowed to
keep working on the movies but whenever
anyone asked him he had to say he was
the new guy to satisfy harrison ford for
the rest of his star wars career rose
wanted to apologize but he only got to
see ford while in full act bar costume
and it's difficult to talk when you're
trapped in a heavy alien squid puppet
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
star wars are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]